now it is a new year and it's a very
happy new year for one james nesbitt
because you were on the honors list I
was yes when you are oh yeah you're not
instruct off for anything you still owe
me for the show those yeah what did you
get what you get
I got an OBE
yes actually yes choose an excuse and
your mom and dad both sit around well
mom's all right no but Dad was very
pleased dad said about bloody time
actually my friends my friends I think
we're pleased I mean one of them Jason
Ferguson Gregor found of mine he said
order of the bell and about time know
what's exciting it's a day at the palace
for my vote from me and my girls do you
know who you're getting yet uh or not
you get different people do well there's
a whole family of them oh there isn't
there's no to them I do I wasn't aware
that um there's like a pack of cards I
think you go to the palace tier I don't
know I mean awesome not make a Edward
good no
cuz rape you what you haven't got
anything yet you should you're you're
genuinely posh JC element I've a feeling
whatever chances you have Romi I get a
chance
no because in the new show yeah you do a
version of one of them yeah do you yes
Camilla it's a lovely time being her
I'll present you with your baby I'll do
it now would you like how to do it
oh yeah I love being her yeah because
it's quite specific she is yeah what is
it is it when do you do I did with in my
show which comes out next Monday we'll
talk about it for this that's your bit
right
don't don't shine the light there right
and yeah a genius genius makeups and
things and mime various people yeah but
she's tough she's a tough she's a tough
character your Camila yes she bakes a
lot and she's you know dealing with
horses a lot and she picks up the phone
and it's Charles does hello sexy like
it's very affectionate very affectionate
get one of those things at the palace no
you're really not
yes is it odd that your very first show
in America was the one that spawned the
Simpson yes so did you like are you a
creator of The Simpsons I breastfed the
yellow people yeah yes we the bodied
little cartoon segments you know his
bumpers on the show and there was this
blue hair and of Marge I remember that
specifically and then I was so busy
doing all these parts on the show and
then they came he said we need something
to do record the voices you know 2-under
and generally okay I'm gone
always wise so she was March dan dan
Castellaneta said okay I don't wait up
for you up you won't want me to be so
he's homework and that was in that very
first week and then that no I knew it
was big I think I went to Italy direct
some of my holiday and there was like
Italian you know Simpsons a bath for
Marilyn oh yeah The Simpsons started on
my show and what yes
I think for five years old anyway I
passed by this little child I just
looked at this boy he is burst into
tears oh I don't think I look like I'm
at all
well good picture John Hannah where is
my John Hannah right now couple yeah you
do to the beach I wouldn't mind looking
like him there it looks great